[موسيقى]
كان نادي مانشستر يونايتد في خضم التغلب
على رقم ليفربول القياسي لعدد الالقاب
المحليه في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
وبالطبع فرضت المنافسه المحتدمه بين
ناديين فوزهما في كاس اوروبا ومحاوله
اغلاق الفجوه بين مانشستر يونايتد
وليفربول فيما يتعلق بعدد الانتصارات في
كاس اوروبا ودوري الابطال لذا اصبح الامر
مصب تركيز فيرجسون لم يكونوا قد فازوا
بدوري الابطال منذ عام
1999 وكان رونالدو متنبها الى حقيقه انه
لن يعتبر كواحدا من اعظم اللاعبين في
العالم ما لم يكن في حوزته فوز بدوري
الابطال
وشعر حتما بسعاده شخصيه عارمه بعد التغلب
على ميسي الذي يلعب مع فريق برشلونه في
مواجهه الذهاب والاياب في نصف النهائي ثم
ذهبوا الى موسكو لمواجهه تشيلسي في
النهائي وكان نادي تشيلسي انذاك الفريق
الجديد البارز فيما يتعلق بدعامه كره
القدم الانجليزيه حيث كان الرومان
ابرموفيتش يمول النادي وكان ناديا عظيما
بالفعل
بالنسبه الى المباراه كان الطرفان يعرف
احدهما الاخر حق المعرفه وربما في شكل
حتمي رونالدو هو الذي كسر التعادل مانحا
مانشستر الصداره لكن فريق تشيلسي قوي وسدد
فرانك لمبارد هدف التعادل من جديد وكان
الفريقان على سويه واحده بالفعل استمرت
المباراه حتى الليل حين حقق مانشستر الفوز
اخيرا بالركلات الترجيحيه اصبح في امكان
رونالدو الاحتفال كفائزا في دوري الابطال
لكنه كان لاعب مانشستر الوحيد الذي اخفق
في التسديد الامر الذي من المرجح انه كدر
صفوه في تلك الامسيه الى حد ما
صد الكره
تمت امور مقدره الحصول فحسب
الرجل الذي لم يتوقف عن احراز الاهداف
طوال الموسم قد توقف في منتصف الركض ونجح
بيتر تشيك في صد الكره لكنه حصل على
ميداليه الفوز في دوري الابطال اخيرا وحصل
مانشستر على الكاس للمره الاولى منذ عقد
تقريبا
كانت مسيرته مع يونايتد في ازدهار وبفضل
اداءه الاستثنائي في موسم 2007 2008 فاز
رونالدو بجائزه الكره الذهبيه الاولى
ليصنف اخيرا كافضل لاعب في العالم